you're saying you're the main player
you're not the mpc well i think we're
dealing with all npcs at this point i
mean depending on how you want to like
very i would say very advanced npcs like
incredibly advanced
npcs compared to uh fallout or something
you know we've got a lot of conversation
options happening here
there's not like four things you can
pick from yeah but there's a whole uh
illusion of free will that's happening
we really do
depending where you are in in the world
feel like you're free to decide any
trajectory in your life that you want
which is pretty funny right for an npc
is pretty it's nice well you're gonna
want that if we're making a video game
you do want to give your npcs the
illusion of free will because it's going
to make interactions with them that's
yeah that much more intense
yeah
so i wonder on the
path to that
how how hard is it to create this is the
sort of the carmack question of um
a realistic virtual world
that's as cool as this one not fully
realistic but sufficiently realistic
that it's
as interesting to live in because that
we're gonna create those worlds
on the path to creating something
like a simulation yes like long long
long before it'll be virtual worlds
where we want to stay forever because
they're full of they're full of uh
that balance of suffering and joy of
limitations and freedoms and all that
kind of stuff a lot of people think like
in the virtual world i can't wait to be
able to
i don't know
have sex with anybody i want or have
anything i want but i think that's not
going to be fun
you want the limitations the constraints
oh you have to battle for the things you
want okay but okay but yeah great video
games yeah one of my favorite video game
memories was like i started playing
world of warcraft and it's original
incarnation
and i didn't even know that you were
gonna have flying mounts like i didn't
even know so i've been running around
dealing with all the encumbrances of
like being an undead warlock that can't
fly but then all of a sudden holy [ __ ]
there's flying mounts and now the world
you've been running around
not flying you're seeing it from the top
down there it's just really cool like
whoa i could do this now and then that
gets boring but a really well-designed
game
it it has a series of these i don't know
what you call it uh
extra abilities that kind of unfold and
produce novelty and then eventually you
just accept it you take it for granted
and then another
novelty appears so those extra abilities
are always balanced with the limitations
the constraints they run up against
because a a well-balanced video game
the challenge the struggle matches the
new ability yeah and sometimes causes
problems on its own
i mean and so to go back to
this universe's simulation
it's really designed like a pretty
awesome video game if you look at it
from the perspective of history i mean
people were on horses they didn't know
that they were going to be bullet trains
they didn't know that you could get in a
car and drive across the country in a
few days that would have sounded
ridiculous we're doing that now and even
in our own lifespan think about it how
long has vr goggles existed like the
ones that you could just buy at best buy
i had the original oculus rift the
[ __ ] puke machine you put that thing
on your i gave it to my friend he went
and vomited in my driveway and people
were making fun of it they were saying
this isn't going to catch on it's too
big it's unwieldy the graphics suck and
then look at where it's at now
and that's going to keep
that trajectory is going to keep
improving so yeah i think that
we are dealing with what you're talking
about which is novelty met with
more problems met with novelty
you